ae
a mão no gol
boa tarde me pediram que eu falasse um
pouco do projeto sabe quem é de porto
alegre rio grande do sul sabe que pra
mim não é muito fácil mas esta é a
fábrica de gaiteiros resumidamente é
quando eu comecei a tocar existiam
fábricas de gaitas no rio grande do sul
no brasil e em determinado momento todas
elas para desativar a gente ficou super
dependente do do instrumento importado
ou usado
então a idéia do projeto é exatamente
resgatar a fabricação do instrumento
agente fábrica essas gatinhos muito
baixo e só não é uma fábrica de gaitas
porque uma fábrica de gaitas vende o seu
produto que é a gaita gente é o nome do
projeto fábrica de gaiteiros porque
exatamente a nós o nosso lucro é a
música é a música que sai um instrumento
a gente não comercializa a gente fábrica
e vão para as escolas nós estamos com
oito escolas e em sete cidades e
atendemos 230 240 crianças de 7 a 15
anos com aulas gratuitas
eles podem levar a respeitam pra casa
pra poder estudar tem aquela hora de
aula e depois nos leva pra casa pra
aprender a estudar entrega para o outro
aluno e assim como se fosse um livro de
uma biblioteca
então esta é a fábrica de gaiteiros
o papel
ae
galera
à época cannon
ae
ganhei uma pergunta
o
ae
o gol
é bom e nos despedimos então com um
ritmo bem bem gaúcho que é o vanerão bom
a despedida obrigada bom bom encontro e
bons trabalhos
ae
olha
caramba